that is why the further negotiations are  only possible when  or after russia would liberate all of  those territories that they are  controlling  illegally now  and i said about the window of  possibilities and i said that it  couldn't be so because in this  what about what  about what possibilities we are speaking  if in this window we see each day guns  and fighting from russian side that's  why they have first of all go away from  our territory and then we'll see what  will be there and i said slow  glory to you thank you so much it's  important  and i want to express my gratitude to  all parties for their support  of productivity  him